overseas brexit is now a done deal after
nearly a half-century of membership
Britain has withdrawn from the European
Union brexit supporters celebrated as
the historic departure became formal on
Friday now and as the UK begins a new
chapter the first order of business will
include negotiations over trade and
security Roxana Saberi is in our London
newsroom with the story Roxana good
morning good morning people here in the
UK are waking up for the first time in
47 years no longer official members of
the European Union it's been a long road
to get here and the journeys not over
yet it's taken three and a half years
for Britain to say goodbye to the EU
a farewell that thousands of brexit
supporters celebrated last night in
London listen this is a good man
we got country back this country seems
just as divided today as it was
unreferenced a moment I think
[Music]
in the immediate future not much will
happen Britain's flag has come down at
the European Parliament but the UK will
still pay its EU dues and be subject to
EU rules for the rest of this year
a deadline Britain has also given itself
to negotiate a new trade agreement with
the EU and the u.s. among others as the
departure clock counted down on the
Prime Minister's residence Boris Johnson
who swept into office vowing to get
brights it done said it worked to unite
the country and lead it ahead this is
the moment when the dawn breaks and the
curtain goes up on a new act in our
great national drama it was less
restraint outside Parliament where
crowds cheered on Nigel Faraj who's
dedicated his political life toward this
moment we know that this is the single
most important moment in the modern
history of our great nation Faraj is
reportedly planning to fly to Washington
for president fronts State of the Union
address on Tuesday the president
encouraged brexit but it's not clear
what kind of trade deal Britain can
expect from him Michelle Roxana thank
you